[Música]
Hola soy Marina sardinha y les doy la
bienvenida a este programa especial de
France 24 en el que vamos a hablar de
los movimientos feministas en contextos
musulmanes a raíz del levantamiento
social en Irán de este año iniciamos con
un breve repaso por la historia de esta
lucha que no es homogénea en 1923 la
egipcia Judas saharaui se convierte en
el primer referente feminista árabe
fundó la unión feminista egipcia para
luchar por el derecho al voto y a la
educación de las mujeres las luchas
feministas en Países Árabes Estuvieron
muy ligadas a los procesos de
Independencia y a los nacionalismos
árabes los años 70 tras el fracaso del
pan arabismo un movimiento laico se
produce una reis lazación de las
sociedades y un retroceso en materia de
derechos para las mujeres en los años 90
nace el feminismo islámico
principalmente en Europa y Estados
Unidos este aboga por una interpretación
del Corán y de las leyes islámicas
hagamos ahora una radiografía si bien
cada país árabe tiene sus propias leyes
y contextos hay similitudes en la
vulneración de los derechos de las
mujeres y niñas también avances en túnez
es el único país musulmán que permite el
aborto por libre decisión de la mujer en
el primer trimestre de gestación otro
tema controvertido es la violencia
doméstica que no está penalizada en la
mayoría de los países de medio oriente
así como la protección de los abusos
sexuales todavía en algunos países las
leyes protegen al violador si este se
casa con la víctima al contrario el
matrimonio entre personas del mismo sexo
acarrea apenas de cárcel e incluso penas
de muerte en países como Arabia Saudita
Qatar o yemen el Líbano las mujeres
están luchando por la igualdad salarial
pero también para que puedan traspasar
su nacionalidad a sus hijos algo que es
negado en países como Siria o
precisamente este año las mujeres
iranísco para los titulares tras el
asesinato de la joven kurdo iraní maxa
mini en septiembre después de ser
detenida por la policía de la moral por
no llevar el jab como marca la
obligatoriedad del Código de vestimenta
iraní la siraní se lanzaron a las calles
liderando las protestas más masivas en
los últimos años una muestra de cómo la
nueva generación ha perdido el miedo a
reclamar sus derechos y también un pulso
para el régimen de la república islámica
que reprimió brutalmente las
manifestaciones nuestra corresponsal
entera Catalina Gómez Ángel nos cuenta
de Dónde surge esta lucha las mujeres
han liderado los cambios en Irán incluso
antes de la Revolución islámica en 1979
ya se estaban a la vanguardia de la
sociedad Incluso en 1979 cuando fue esa
Revolución ella se estuvieron en la
calle y tuvieron gran protagonismo en
esas protestas pero luego cuando subió
esta nueva República islámica y el poder
claricael tuvo el poder fueron puestas a
un lado incluso mujeres que compartían
esos valores y Esa visión de la
República islámica también fueron
aisladas y un ejemplo es ver ese sistema
de poder de la república islámica donde
las mujeres no tienen presencia con los
años las mujeres tomaron otras vías para
luchar por el cambio lo hicieron también
a nivel privado y nivel Industrial pero
muchas de las activistas salieron a la
calle a hacer y a contarle a otras
mujeres especialmente en provincia y
sectores más tradicionales Cuáles eran
sus derechos los de ellas y lo de los
niños muchas de ellas fueron capturadas
fueron exiliadas todos esos movimientos
han sido reprimidos y dos de las mujeres
más importantes actualmente la abogada
nastrid so today narges muhammadhi están
en prisión por esa lucha de defensa de
las mujeres por eso Es bien interesante
ver como esta nueva generación de
mujeres las más jóvenes lideran hoy esa
lucha por el cambio muchas son hijas de
mujeres que fue vieron reprimidas sus
sueños Su futuro por la república
islámica Y no quieren repetir lo mismo
que hicieron sus mamás por eso prefieren
arriesgar sus vidas y ir a prisión ser
torturadas en ciertos casos pero aún así
dejan ese miedo atrás porque no quieren
repetir lo que repitieron sus madres por
eso se quitan ese velo que para ellas es
el símbolo de toda esa represión de la
república islámica
vamos a conversar ahora sobre estos
movimientos feministas en los países de
mayoría musulmana y con distintas
interseccionalidades que atraviesan las
luchas feministas en medio oriente y así
como los retos pendientes y para
analizar esto tenemos con nosotras a
mimont hamido yaguia ella es escritora y
activista feminista bienvenida a France
24 mimos brevemente quería preguntarte
para empezar si nos puedes hacer una
radiografía de los derechos de las
mujeres en los Países Árabes
Hola buenos días encantada de estar con
vosotras Bueno un resumen no puedo hacer
porque claro las mujeres musulmanas no
somos una cosa monolítica y todas somos
iguales y en todos los países tenemos
los mismos derechos son las mismas
carencias
los países musulmanes son muchos y
el islam no es monolítico y en cada país
hay las mujeres tienen unos derechos
donde y en otros países las mujeres
carecen de eso mismo derechos por
ejemplo en el norte de África donde yo
soy yo nací en el norte de África
existen las leyes de familia existen en
Marruecos en Argelia existen en túnez en
Libia
que constriñe muy duramente los derechos
de las mujeres
Si nos vamos a allá a repúblicas
teocráticas como como Irán o
repúblicastocráticas como Arabia saudí
los derechos son mucho mucho menores los
derechos de las mujeres o sea van a una
progresión de norte de norte a sur
si hablamos del mundo éramos musulmán si
hablamos del mundo ahora vamos musulmán
menos derechos y hablamos de los
musulmanes en Asia o en otros países
también cambia es diferente mi montt y
también desde occidente hemos visto a
las mujeres musulmanas o se ha visto
como una mujer sumisa Incluso se han
llegado a justificar guerras e
invasiones como la invasión de
Afganistán para la liberación de la
mujer afgana que ha supuesto esto a lo
largo de la historia
bueno a ver es que las mujeres estén
sometidas no significa que sean mujeres
sumisas las mujeres a las mujeres no les
queda más remedio que aceptar esa
sumisión
la excusa de la invasión de Afganistán
por parte de Estados Unidos para invadir
un país eso es una excusa como otra cual
o como otra cualquiera el problema de
Afganistán tampoco es solo religioso que
lo es lo es no hay que negarlo es
religioso pero hay que mirar la historia
de Afganistán para saber que es un país
que ha sido siglos y siglos durante
siglos ha llevado una política feudal
sobre todo una estructura feudal donde
el hombre está aquí arriba y las mujeres
no existen donde el hombre y la mujer
están tan segregados tan separados que
no se conocen los hombres no conocen a
las mujeres y las mujeres no conocen a
los hombres de hecho cuando son pequeños
ya se separan separan a los niños de las
niñas
de las mujeres para que no tengan
contacto con lo cual yo siempre digo que
la segregación es la muchos males y ahí
está uno de los problemas hay uno de los
problemas luego además claro
no escapa no escapa
a las políticas
de las potencias accidentales como
Estados Unidos no
donde parece que es que conviene que
estos países sigan en ese en ese en esa
oscuridad no
Y usted tiene un libro que se titula no
nos taparán en el que analizas la
imposición de las normas patriarcales a
través del velo con esta revolución del
jiyab que está habiendo ahora mismo en
Irán qué supone esta obligatoriedad del
velo para las mujeres
A ver
primero tenemos que pensar si estamos
apostando tanto en occidente como en
cualquier parte del mundo por los
valores universales si estamos que hay
que apostar por los valores universales
de libertad de igualdad etcétera
etcétera evidentemente
mi lucha contra el gyapes de hace muchos
años y hay gente que considera considera
que ya no es lo más importante pero es
que ya es lo que representa es el
símbolo de esa opresión
y no solo es el símbolo O sea no solo
representa esa opresión además visualiza
visibiliza
esa ideología que no religión porque hay
que diferenciar entre ideología y
religión esa ideología islamista en el
espacio público en la calle
cómo cómo es tan fácil No es muy fácil
que esa esa ideología islamista extrema
además que que lleva años imponiéndose
visible en la calle a través de las
mujeres porque ponerle un a las mujeres
es muy fácil es barato y
sale rentable cuando tú ves un hombre
por la calle no sabes si es musulmán o
si es judío o si es cristiano pero si
ves una mujer por la calle sabes
perfectamente que es musulmana
es el símbolo de todas las opresiones
que recibimos las mujeres de todas
mi mood Y por qué desde las sociedades
occidentales también desde las mujeres
musulmanas muchas veces que viven en
occidente Usan el jiyab como un símbolo
identitario también como un símbolo de
Colonial nos puedes contar un poquito
sobre esto qué opina bueno porque
estamos inmersos en una marea de
identidades ahora todo es identidad es
muy fácil hablar de identidades cuando
la identidad es algo que tú vas formando
conformando a lo largo de tu vida y la
identidad no te la da un símbolo ni te
la da y bueno no te la da una religión
porque Claro si estamos validando
identidad religiosas estamos haciendo lo
mismo que están haciendo las teocracias
estamos haciendo lo mismo que hacía el
fascismo en España por ejemplo en España
cuando cuando vivía Franco y era una
dictadura si no eras católico
o sea católico no eras español estamos
haciendo eso y es un juego muy peligroso
que que está que se está haciendo sobre
todo en occidente no sé si por
desconocimiento por conveniencia o por
una mezcla de las dos cosas mi mood y
brevemente se está hablando también de
feminismo islámico cuéntanos que es esta
corriente y si realmente el feminismo
laico y el feminismo islámico se pueden
conciliar
bueno el feminismo es uno es universal
como es uno y es universal es persé anti
racista con lo cual yo soy de las
feministas que opinan que él divide y
vencerás Y eso es lo que se está
haciendo No hay feminismos hay feminismo
y el feminismo es anti racista per se lo
que hay que pedirle al anti racismo es
que sea de una vez feminista el
feminismo islámico
intenta es un oxímoron en sí mismo es
imposible es imposible justificar el
feminismo a través de una religión eso
no lo han hecho ni las mujeres
cristianas ni las mujeres judías porque
no se puede Ese es Yo siempre digo que
el feminismo islámico es un caramelo
envenenado que nos ha regalado la
ideología y la mixta no la religión la
ideología islamista para que las mujeres
nos callemos y nos conformemos
con lo cual no es que haya una
Reconciliación o no haya no tenga que
haber una Reconciliación hay que hay que
saber la historia del feminismo islámico
se creó en España lo crearon conversos y
lo creó un señor Manzur escudero en las
alpujarras de granada o sea cuando tú
sabes esa historia pues tú sabes que eso
de feminismo tiene que tener bien poco
no
Muchísimas gracias mi buen jamiro
escritora marroquí por estar con
nosotros y por esta conversación pues
tan enriquecedora y que aporta a esta
lucha de los movimientos feministas que
se están dando Pues en todo el mundo
Muchas gracias por estar con nosotros
Muchas gracias a vosotros llegamos así
al final de esta emisión a ustedes
Muchas gracias por su atención sigan con
nosotros en France 24.com
[Música]